Jason is with us in Columbia South
Carolina hi Jason how are you hey Dave
I'm doing great how you been better than
I deserve what's up Dave I've got a
question for you I don't think I've ever
heard you answer it but I know that you
teach that when it comes to investments
you're big on mutual funds as well as
tabes or investment property yes when it
comes to a paid-for investment property
it could take me a significant time to
save a hundred thousand-plus for say a
duplex or a townhome but it could take
me significantly less time to save up
the pace for a condo to use as a rental
property how do you feel about that
that's what you take on something that
would have a regime feed to it and that
might cost a little bit less but would
be a good location I own a couple of
condos they're fine the thing you want
to look for here is this of equal price
in an equal neighborhood in other words
if you're going to buy a $100,000 condo
or $100,000 house in the same
neighborhood same within a mile radius
kind of thing
on average the single-family is probably
going to go up more in value now a
well-placed condo will obviously go up
faster than a bad neighborhood
single-family you follow me yeah and so
condos are fine you just have to think
about what you're getting into and
obviously you have to look at what the
HOA dues are going to be the condo fees
are going to be is the condo association
being managed well and that's probably
that in the neighborhood of the two
biggest concerns I have when I'm buying
a condo because a lot of condo
associations are very poorly managed and
if they don't keep up the maintenance
and they don't keep a certain percentage
of the complex to be owner-occupied
versus rental you'll lose the condo
association or the condo complex will
lose the ability to get normal permanent
financing and if they can't get FHA or
VA financing in there or our
conventional financing in there then the
values are going to drop
like a rock because you only got cash
buyers and investor buyers at that point
and so you just got to watch and make
sure that they're managing their ratios
of a home owners of owners
owner-occupied versus tenants and that
they're that they're doing the
maintenance and they're properly
managing the the finances of the condo
association but if you've done that
which doesn't take long to do you just
call the management company and you know
get the realtor that's involved if it's
listed to look at and pull up the you
know the documentation most of the time
its public is not hard to get ahold of
from the management company on how you
know what are the reserves for roof what
are the reserves from the paint parking
lot and are they collecting enough to
pay their bills and are they paying
their bills then you look back up and
start looking at you okay if I drove up
in this thing and I was a buyer is this
is this a condo project I want to have
my wife in do I want to live in here and
or what a normal reasonable person want
to live in here and if the answer is yes
then you probably got a good solid condo
complex and it's fine to do my
son-in-law Winston runs all of our real
estate and he does some investing on his
own and he bought a condo the other day
as an investment so they're fine and you
just don't want to get a junky one and
one that's that's poorly run that the
management's poorly run those two things
will make you wish you didn't but other
than that I'm fine with it hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show so you
have to break the cycle you have to flip
this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind
you